[Musique]
réunis dans une petite salle de
l'hôpital ils ont regardé avec attention
la cérémonie du jour du souvenir
l'hôpital héberge 75 anciens combattants
la plupart de la guerre de corée ils ont
en moyenne 97 ans et une grande
solidarité les anime quand je voudrais
qu'on a eus l'armée qui venaient nous a
aidés durant la première phase la
pandémie en ce militaire et puis nos
vétérans ya vraiment un lien qui est
très spécial est privilégiée vincent
lavoie à 102 ans il a fait la campagne
d'italie et il est fier de nous montrer
ses six médailles si c'est difficile il
fallait se méfier à ouchy il faudrait
attaquer mais je défends dauchy projet
lemire lui à 90 ans il a fait la guerre
de corée dans l'infanterie du royal 22e
régiment ça a été une belle expérience
en début parce que je les ai tous les
experts tous elle devait perdu des amis
lara et perdu des amis n'est perdu
pour vous dire un homme un
hivernage en moins chaque chien
j'ai avis
ils ont été à terre il inquiète temps
mais vraiment yves bergeaud 97 ans s'est
enrôlé à 17 ans en faisant croire qu'il
en avait 19 qu'il a connu le
débarquement de normandie à caen en
france était à peu près le puy du
moment
si ça ne peut pas continuer
même à
m'excuser parce que c'est difficile pour
vous vous souvenez en se disant
ah oui
issigeac bissonnet radio-canada sainte
anne de bellevue